[Applause]
boys learn your lesson
what is a human fire hydrant you know
it's that thing of when high-waisted
midgets I know I'm doing great
yes it's important that people know what
this is the bar I'm getting that nothing
except for my baby carrots there's a
special guest have you heard of Blacula
the black dracula yes well they have a
Jewish Dracula Oh what's his name Sidney
Applebaum this place has everything
asbestos lupus the magazine's at
Supercuts Danny
[Applause]
that's right sometimes we get so caught
up in loving our own family we forget
about
loving everyone in the world I guess
that's kind of what I don't know makes
us all punch a little ball I guess it
kind of yeah yeah bogel checks just
don't let grandma see okay she's a
little old fashioned it's that saying of
when you put a [ __ ] on a skateboard
skateboard slides slides around on your
floor eating garbage
kay Bob's cookie crisps
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Stefan I I don't think anyone's
reassured by the presence of food
Roombas
[Applause]
located in an abandoned white fish
factory middle is real charity
flaccid outreach group Doctors Without
boners built on a dare by 90 year old
club promoter Fuji house their MD
moonlight lava land
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Kiwis spied we have
[Laughter]
he's gonna double duty yeah
opened in 2017 on the Upper East Side of
a dumpster
it's that thing where you tie a string
to a [ __ ] and a windbreaker and then
run through a field this 24-hour
[ __ ] is the creation of club owner
Rabbi Judah and his knees look like
biscuits and he's ready to party
so I'm sorry it wasn't it was not Mick
Jagger no wasn't this dagger the fat kid
with this cousin did I do that Stefan if
I were you I would be asking myself all
that's I know I do a doorman who always
high-fives children of divorce
[Laughter]
this wealthy whack Shack whack Shack
opened its doors in the two hours
between when Farrah Fawcett and Michael
Jackson died I don't trust any dog his
stomach touches the ground so lay it on
me my man what's your question
Barak mit Jewish Cupid's fool they just
want you to meet someone nice and
federal - yeah
[Applause]
this gang ridden skateboard park with
the ceremony spot for Verne Troyer's
2004 wedding what is a human sequence
it's that thing of when a [ __ ] on
rollerskates
where is all of your clothes and then
you pull them through an inner poor
peeps TED Talks
Roman J is real ex-cop based on the
novel push by Sapphire the outdoor
concert from as Olaf commercial
Roman J is realistic because what's a
human parking cone yes it's that thing
of when two jacked midgets paint
themselves orange and you have to pair a
little part between them
[Applause]
oh it's that thing it's that day thank
you Stefan
[Applause]